[Music]
hey you guys it's another installment in
my halloween eek week series my extra
movie reviews that i'm doing the week of
halloween and as halloween gets closer
and closer i kind of feel i kind of felt
like doing more i don't know necessarily
like family friendly kind of stuff but
stuff that's more on the kind of fun end
of you know halloween movies stuff that
i like to watch around halloween when i
was a kid and uh has been just as much
nowadays so uh by that token here's a
movie that i've been wanting to do it's
so weird because i could have sworn
that tom and i did a movie retrospective
on this because i know that i had
watched it fairly recently like in the
last year or two and i thought that he
had watched it with me but then when i
went back and like checked our channel
like our movie retrospectives i couldn't
find it so either we did it and it got
taken down and i didn't realize or we
thought about doing it and we didn't do
it i don't know it just seems really
weird because i could have sworn that we
did this one and i couldn't find it on
there so if we've already done it
whatever [ __ ] it um i'm doing it again
this is the monster squad from 1987. now
the great thing and i'm sure anybody
that grew up in the 80s or if you know
anything about 80s movies was that 80s
the 80s were kind of like the heyday of
sort of
family friend ostensibly family from
friendly movies that were kind of like
you know horror movies but that kids
could watch also i mean i kind of went
into that a little bit when i was
talking about something wicked this way
comes which you know was kind of like a
disney movie but also had like a lot of
horror elements in it now that one is
kind of like a different vibe because
that was kind of more a serious film
being an adaptation of you know a ray
bradbury dark fantasy story this one it
seems like this one was trying to kind
of cash in on the success of
sort of like more grown up kids fair
kind of like the goonies and stuff like
that where it was like a bunch of kids
going on kind of a scary adventure and
the kids were more like
realistic kids you know like they swore
and they were kind of you know they did
you know naughty things and [ __ ] like
that so there was a lot of those kind of
things so when this came out
you could tell that it was kind of
modeled after that but then it um kind
of had
uh you know a crossover with the you
know old universal monsters like you
know monster movie and want to do kind
of like an old school like monster mash
type of thing but it seems like when
this came out it didn't really find an
audience until later on i think it
really did quite badly at the box office
sadly because
it's almost kind of like i guess
audiences at the time even though they
were sort of more primed to
you know more primed for this kind of
thing where it's like it's kind of like
a horror movie but it's kids
you know it just seemed like maybe this
one was too much because there's some
stuff in this one that even by the very
lack standards of the 80s was maybe
going a little bit too far for like back
then uh you know so it's maybe that's
the possibility of why it never really
caught on
but later on like when it came out on
video and came out on cable
it seemed to like kind of slowly find
its audience to an extent that i mean
nowadays it's such a cult classic
that uh you know the main kid that was
in it you know after he grew up he
actually ended up making a documentary
about it and about like the fandom that
kind of sprung out of it you know in the
interim uh called wolfman's got nards
which obviously is the most famous line
from the film it's just one of those
ones that came out and it just wasn't
appreciated at the time and uh but
happily you know as time went on like
more and more people got and i kind of
feel like kids that grew up in the 80s
this is kind of one that they remember
really fondly from their childhood
interestingly i think i saw this one it
came out on 87 which means i would have
been 15 when this came out so this might
have been like a little bit like aimed
at kids like slightly younger than i was
because i think the main kids in it are
all kind of 12 years old
so i don't think that i saw this in the
theater although this seems like
something that i would have gone to see
because i you know i was into like
monsters and horror and stuff but like i
said it was probably it was probably
like aimed a little too young for me and
it was kind of a shame because i think i
would have appreciated it a lot but i'm
pretty sure i saw it on cable later i
didn't see it i didn't see it as many
times as you know that i saw like the
goonies and things like that and i
always kind of felt like
i remember when i saw it back in the day
like maybe in the late 80s i ended up
first seeing it and i remember
liking it but it not making a huge
impression like i said maybe it was
because i was a little bit older and
then when i watched it again like a few
years back i was kind of like man that
was good but i just there was something
that was lacking about it however when i
watched it again for this review
which you know i just watched it earlier
today i was kind of like man that
actually was like way better than i
remembered it has flaws um you know it's
not as good as the goonies or anything
like that but there's really a lot of
fun [ __ ] about it and honestly
so the more times i see it like the more
i like it the more i appreciate it so
basically this was directed by fred
decker uh who had also done knight of
the creeps which was you know a more
straight up uh horror movie and he was
also one of the writers on house the
1986 one with william cat which i know
we did a review of because i remember
that but uh yeah so and it also uh was
written by co-written by shane black who
did like you know the lethal weapon
movies among many many many other things
so you know so there was that whole so
it had like a really good uh pedigree
now interestingly this kind of got
passed around
to different producers it ended up
getting released by tristar like in
summer of 1987.
and they wanted to do like i said kind
of like your classic
monster mash type of thing like the
universal movies were doing back in the
1940s and stuff like that and they were
when they were starting to kind of go
into like more comedy i guess but i
guess they did a few serious monster
mash ones they did so many back then but
um they wanted to do something like that
however uh universal would actually not
give the filmmakers permission to use
the universal monster designs
so they had to just kind of like i guess
they had like some legal department come
in and you'd be like well you have to
tweak it like this percentage so you can
still tell that it's that monster but
you can't use the exact same designs
that said um i think they did a [ __ ]
great job with the monsters in this one
stan winston did the creature effect so
you know they're gonna kick ass
and all of them look great particularly
the gill man is a particular standout it
looks enough like the universal gill man
that obviously does the gill man but
they changed it just enough uh to get
away with it and it just it looks so
good and honestly i kind of wish the
gill man had like a bigger part because
he's only in like a couple of scenes
dracula and frankenstein's monster are
kind of like the big ones and i guess
the werewolf too i kind of feel like the
two that looked the best like the mummy
and the gill man didn't get enough
screen time so that is kind of one
complaint but all of the all of the
monsters look good all of the actors
that play the monsters look great so
props to stan winston uh the all the
monsters still look fantastic some of
the other special effects especially
like kind of the optical effects there's
kind of like a um
there's like some matte type type of
stuff going on with you know a time
portal and uh you know a vortex or
something like that and there's you know
that looks kind of fake uh you know kind
of around the edges you know when they
do that
that uh matting or whatever that looks
kind of bad and like you know the some
of the bats like look pretty fake and
everything but honestly it's just kind
of like this movie
it's just supposed to be just like a fun
kind of kids movie so you can forgive a
lot of stuff and you know i definitely
forgive it one because it's fun and two
because the monsters look awesome so
there's that whole thing too
interestingly i heard that i'm not sure
if this is entirely true but i think
that fred decker said that the original
director's cut of the monster squad was
actually 13 minutes longer but for
whatever reason i guess the producers
were like no this can't be longer than
90 minutes so he cut a bunch out of it
so now it's like super short it's only
like an hour and 22 minutes long i was
like amazed when i was watching it again
i'm like holy crap and it moves along
like really really quickly
so i don't know how much of the stuff
that was taken out kind of fills in some
of the gaps because one of the main
complaints that i've seen about this
movie even by people that love it and
grew up with it is that the story kind
of like isn't all that fleshed out and
there's like a lot of plot holes like
well how did this how did van helsing's
diary get here and how you know the the
stuff about the amulet and the vortex
and all this other kind of stuff isn't
explained all that well but like i said
it's not really
you don't really have to worry about it
too much uh because really kind of just
the main thrust of the story is just a
group of kids fighting a group of
classic universal
ish monsters and that's really all you
need to know about it i mean yes there's
kind of this complicated lore about why
the monsters are here and you know this
thing that they have to find and all
this other kind of stuff but overall i'm
it's not really something to be worried
about it's just like a fun like family
horror movie that you can put on
although like i said i don't think
i mean obviously this would be fine for
you know kind of older kids or tweens
and stuff like that i don't know if i'd
let like a little little kid watch it
because there's a lot of swearing and um
there's a lot of really there's a lot of
uh
language in it that really is not super
acceptable nowadays so but but it does
kind of like um you know it goes with
the time that's kind of how kids talk to
each other in the 80s um you know so
whether we like it or not and that was
kind of the way you know us kids when i
was a kid in the 80s that's how they
people talk to each other they call
these each other these terrible names
that you would get in a lot more trouble
nowadays than you would back then your
mileage may vary if you want to show it
to your kids or not like i said there's
a lot of a lot of sweaters i'm like you
know like a five-year-old girl calling
someone to chicken [ __ ] stuff like that
which i think is hilarious personally
but i don't have kids so like i said
you're gonna have to use your own
judgment on that over whether you want
to watch it and honestly there is some
stuff in that like people
uh for real get killed in like terrible
ways uh there's a scene where the
werewolf blows up and like blows up into
pieces and so it's like pretty gory and
kind of adult for a kids movie but like
i said there was a lot of that going on
in the 80s although this one
i feel like this is modeled after the
goonies but it has a lot more
stuff in it it's a lot more it has a lot
more swearing it has a lot more gore it
has a lot more like scary [ __ ] but it's
funny too so you know what i mean so if
if the goonies is too scary for like a
little kid then this will for sure be
too scary because you know and too adult
because there's just way more stuff in
here than uh what's going on in the
goonies so what you have here there's
kind of like a little like thing before
the credits roll i guess a hundred years
prior to the events you know the main
events of the movie so i'm guessing um
well let's see it was 1887.
so i guess she got uh van helsing and
some other people and they're trying to
do this ritual
where they're trying to like they have
this girl in there and she's saying some
stuff in like another language and
there's this amulet that's kind of
glowing and uh so they're trying to do
whatever it is and then like all the
monsters are attacking them like all the
vampire brides and you know dracula
comes out and they all get their asses
kicked and then this big vortex opens up
and they kind of get sucked into
wherever it is so then we jump ahead to
present day which like i said is 1987
and we are introduced to a group of
mostly 12 year old kids i mean the main
kid sean is played by uh andre gower and
he's the one that actually went on and
did the uh the documentary wolfman's got
nards later on sadly uh the kid that
plays horus or fat kid as he's generally
known um he actually ended up he gave up
acting like after this when he got a
little bit older and went to law school
but then he died at 22. i believe he
died of pneumonia so that was like oh
that was like a real shame i actually
hadn't known that when i watched the
movie at first but then like i saw it
when i looked it up so i was like that's
uh that's pretty shitty
so yeah it's just this group of kids
and uh this group of kids is really
really into
monsters classic monsters new monsters
they just love and they and they do you
know kid things like boys do and they
just kind of like have
debates about uh you know
what what are the different ways to kill
a werewolf and what would happen if you
like you know blew his head up or
something like that so and all of that
kind of factors into the movie later on
when they actually do get attacked by
actual monsters so but they're just like
having debates but it's kind of like the
kids and stand by me you know what i
mean where it's just kind of like who
would win a fight against like superman
and whatever so it's that kind of
situation so they're all into that and
there's also you know because they're
you know they're kind of misfits you
know it's kind of just kind of like the
goonies one of them has a younger sister
named phoebe who's five who i think
she's like my favorite character she's
adorable and she's kind of always she
likes monsters too and she always kind
of wants to tag along with them but of
course you know they think she's just a
baby so they don't really want to hang
out with her and they also have this kid
who's kind of older his name is rudy and
he's kind of like the kid that kind of
has a motorcycle and a leather jacket
and he smokes i don't think he's a
motorcycle it's like a bike's bicycle
but he kind of rides it like a
motorcycle and uh he's in junior high or
middle school as they would call it
nowadays it's kind of interesting too
because i don't know like people that
didn't grow up in the 80s there was if
you've seen a lot of movies from the 80s
there was this kind of like 50s vibe to
it and there was kind of like a 50s
resurgence like kind of happening in the
80s like people were just into you know
just like you know like i said early 80s
you had kind of like bands like the
stray cats and stuff like that it was
kind of like a rockabilly type of thing
everybody had the big pompadours and
stuff so there was definitely that kind
of thing going on and i definitely do
feel like there was kind of a 50s you
should lay it back to the future and
stuff like that where everybody was
going back to the 50s so there was kind
of like this
resurgence of interest in the 50s in the
80s so that's kind of what you get with
rudy where he looks kind of like a 50s
greaser
and for whatever reason they don't
really go into his backstory but he
starts uh hanging out with these
misfit younger kids and sort of protects
them from like bullies because of course
they get bullied because they're weird
and they like monsters and stuff so he
kind of starts hanging out with them at
their clubhouse it might be because the
clubhouse is right by like one of the
kids
houses and his hot older sister like
sometimes undresses in front of the
window without uh closing her blinds so
that might be why rudy goes in there
because he does kind of look through and
that's another thing too is there's
again there's some kind of questionable
stuff that they probably wouldn't put in
a movie nowadays uh which is probably
true of like a lot of 80s stuff but you
know one particularly where he's like
looking at the naked chick and then
taking pictures of her and then later
they use that like as kind of he uses
that as kind of blackmail uh a little
bit so you know a little bit problematic
i'm just saying but yeah so there's that
whole thing too but uh so yeah so they
they kind of get together and
and hang out read comic books and talk
about monsters and everything like that
meanwhile the monsters from the past
that van helsing had been fighting
uh they got sucked into this vortex or
whatever and for whatever reason got
dumped in 1987 which was 100 years later
so it was kind of like i said it's kind
of like
the vortex isn't super explained like is
it a time portal is it like supposed to
take the evil out of the world they kind
of explain it but it doesn't really make
any sense but like i said don't really
worry about it it's not important it's
just like a fun movie
so uh that for whatever reason there's
like a plane and it's like a world war
ii plane and the two pilots are on it
and then they say to each other they
exposition to each other that is like
they're carrying these coffins of like
dead dudes to wherever and uh so it
turns out that one of them is dracula so
dracula kind of busts out and one of the
other ones is frankenstein's monster so
he kind of he doesn't kill the pilots
but they do kind of like drop out the
plane like dracula turns into a bat or
whatever and follows uh frankenstein's
monster's uh coffin down and they kind
of land in this swamp
near this town where these kids live
this group of monsters
dracula is like the leader right and
then so there's other there's other ones
too frankenstein's monster he kind of
like uh you know revives him with
lightning and then there's also the gill
man who's already there for whatever
reason like he's already in the swamp
then there's also the mummy who actually
comes to life i guess he was in the
museum like the local museum and he just
like comes to life and walks off and
then there's also the wolf man who
i can't remember where did the wolf man
come from i don't even remember where
the wolf came from at this point like i
said it doesn't matter they're just
trying to like monster mash all of these
uh all of these monsters together so
they can like you know square off
against the kids or whatever
so obviously the first thing that
happens like all this weird [ __ ] starts
happening like the wolf man who is still
in his man form
actually goes to the police station and
tells them you guys need to lock me up
because i'm a werewolf and it's the full
moon and i'm gonna [ __ ] everybody up and
everything but of course they do not
believe him they just think he's crazy
and one of the kids their dad is a cop
so the cop is just sitting there like
i'm too old for this [ __ ] it's like why
like what the [ __ ] is going on like a
dude's coming in saying he's like a
werewolf and all this other kind of
crazy crap going on another thing that
happens too is shawn like the main kid
uh his mom finds this book like knows
he's into monsters and so she finds this
book ostensibly at a garage sale it's
like oh they had a garage sale from that
like old creepy mansion or whatever and
uh she brings this book which was
written by van helsing
and he is really excited about it but
then he's like well wait it's all in
german and he can't read it
so they first try to get the older
sister to read it because she takes
german but of course she's a ditzy
dumbass and like she doesn't know how to
read it so then they have to approach
who they call i don't i think they ever
even give this guy a name he's just
known as scary german guy and he lives
in the neighborhood and he's always kind
of like peeking out the window like the
kids walking by and they just think he's
creepy and weird
because he's like a weird foreigner or
whatever so uh so they're kind of scared
to go there but they're like look we
really need this book translated
so we can see what's going on because by
this point they've started to like
suspect that there's monsters so they
finally go to scary german guy's house
to ask him to translate the book and it
turns out that scary german guy is a
lovely lovely man he translates
translates the book for them so it's
through this book that you get the
backstory about this amulet which
supposedly is i think it's like
concentrated good
and it's supposed to like keep the all
the forces of evil away and keep the
monsters away however there's like a
little loophole that every hundred years
if like the evil kind of gets hold of
the amulet they can break it and then
like all the evil forces you know the
monsters can take over
and like it'll tip the balance of the
world toward the evil side so to prevent
that from happening there's kind of like
another loophole where you can get
a virgin but it has to be a female
virgin i don't think they say that in
the book but
in the movie they are always talking we
need to find a virgin but it's always a
girl because i'm kind of like well i'm
sure like those 12 year old boys are all
virgins too like couldn't they do it but
no it has to be a girl i don't remember
if it says specifically that it had to
be a girl virgin but it does uh because
virginity only matters if it's a girl i
guess i don't know it's really weird but
uh there was a lot of that in the 80s
now that i'm thinking about it it was
just going they said virgin it's kind of
like they almost went well maybe now i
guess not because there was also that
really funny
uh vampire comedy with a very young jim
carrey in it i think lauren hutton was
in a tickle once bitten and she i guess
because she was a female vampire she was
looking for a male virgin
so yeah so there were male virgins in
movies too i'm so i'm just like you know
i'm just talking about my ass apparently
but yeah so it has to be a girl virgin
so a girl virgin has to like say this
spell which will open the portal up
again and they'll like suck all the
monsters into it and either
take them into limbo i think they do say
that it takes them into limbo or just
pushes them ahead another 100 years and
makes them somebody else's problem i'm
not really sure what uh what the end
game is but like i said it's not super
important
so so that all of that is established
it's also established too that even
though dracula
is the head of the monsters and mummy
seems to be on his team gilman seems to
be on his team
wolfman is on his team but only when
he's in wolf mode when he's a man he's
almost kind of like [ __ ] this [ __ ] i
mean you know with that which makes
sense and frankenstein
or frankenstein's monster he kind of
seems like he's in it but he's kind of
real um
passive and submissive and everything
and dracula like keeps him in a dungeon
and is mean to him so
there's one great scene where phoebe the
little five-year-old girl it's you know
very much like the original frankenstein
movie uh where she's kind of sitting by
the by a lake and like pulling flowers
out of the thing
and frankenstein's monster like
approaches her and then so it turns out
that phoebe like befriends frankenstein
it's like no he's nice and he's like his
friend of ours so now like all the kids
start hanging out with frankenstein's
monster and because frankenstein's
monster you know calls dracula master
and everything like that so he's able to
kind of like help the kids
figure out where dracula is because
dracula is not only trying to get the
amulet
but he's so he can destroy it but he's
also trying to get van helsing's diary
for some reason so he can like figure
something out or or how to destroy the
amulet or something like that like i
said it's not super important if they do
say it in the movie but it's not that
big a deal so
so it goes on where
uh basically so the kids are trying to
like fight the monsters and the monsters
are trying to like kill the kids and get
the amulet and the book away from them
and it's like this big confrontation
toward the end now as i said
this movie has a lot of stuff in it that
i really think
was even for the 80s was kind of like
okay because there's one point like i
said where the werewolf he is like the
the cop guy like the dad of one of the
kids like puts some dynamite or a
grenade or some [ __ ] like that like down
the front of his pants and then like
pushes him out a window and the werewolf
like legitimately like explodes and like
you see
like arms and head and everything like
that like but like you know blowing up
and like blood and gore and stuff and so
then like he's laying down in pieces on
the ground and he does kind of come back
together because that was kind of one of
the things that they were discussing
earlier on in the movie was that well
you know how many ways are there to kill
a werewolf because they were doing the
test for the older kid to see if he
could be in the monster club
and um he said well silver bullet and
then they couldn't think of any more um
so that was kind of like so they blew
him up and then like all of his pieces
came back together and he like
regenerated uh so that at the end they
were just kind of like oh i guess silver
bullet is the only way because you can
blow him up and he still like came back
to life
so there was that whole issue too
there's also a very creepy scene well
because at first they get um one of the
boys hot older sisters
because she tells them that she's a
virgin
so they are trying to get her to
complete the ritual you know what i mean
so all the monsters are kind of like um
you know coming in on them and and
everything and she's she can't read
german obviously so she's having like
scary german guy like help her try to
read it out of this book but of course
she's like an idiot so she's like i
can't say that like speak english blah
blah blah because she's like a ditz and
so she can't do it and then but finally
she does it and then like nothing
happens and then they're like wait
you're not really a virgin are you and
she's like yeah but well steve but he
doesn't count and they're just like [ __ ]
this and then at this point and i think
like modern audiences might think this
is very very strange but at this point
like phoebe the five-year-old girl is
there and they're like well she's a
virgin right i'm like well i would hope
so for christ
how dark would that be if they like had
the five-year-old girl like read the
thing they're like oh my god she's not a
person either that would be terrible but
yeah so so that's a little weird like
thinking of a five-year-old girl that's
like thinking if we're in those terms
like i said i don't think they would do
that in a movie nowadays but uh yeah but
they did it back then and also there's a
scene well like i said eve i think even
audiences back then were just kind of
like whoa that was a little far where
dracula is gonna kill phoebe cause she's
there like trying to open the vortex and
she has the amulet in her hand and
dracula legit like picks her up by the
face like picks her up like that and
screams right in her face give me the
amulet you [ __ ]
this is a little big little
five-year-old girl
dracula calls a five-year-old girl a
[ __ ]
this is probably like the only movie in
history where that happens
but it happens in this movie but i mean
despite all of that despite the [ __ ]
that's in this it's just and like i said
the the [ __ ] the swearing i mean the
kids are just like always like swearing
and they're just calling each other all
of these horrible slurs and stuff like
that that no one would you that you know
that you wouldn't see in a movie
nowadays but it's like for whatever
reason i guess because it was the 80s
and the movie was fun and like
well-intentioned and
it's just
you know it so it works and even though
i don't know so i just kind of feel like
it fell into this you know when it first
came out at least it fell into this
thing where
it was a little too adult
for the kids that it was aiming for
because like i said i'm imagining they
were going for like a tween demographic
because that's how old most of the kids
were in the in the movie they were about
around 12. so i imagine they were going
for that demographic but maybe parents
thought the movie was a little bit too
old for them but then like older
teenagers it was probably like a little
too kid movie for them because like i
said i was 15 when this came out and it
seemed like i mean i probably would have
seen it anyway but it seemed a little
bit like a kids movie at that point
which it is
but
it has like some pretty adult [ __ ] in it
and i had forgotten another thing too
i'm pretty sure like i was watching this
this morning two of the cops like one of
the cops um is you know one of the kids
dads right
like uh sean's dad is a cop and his
partner who like some the the
interactions between sean's dad the cop
and his partner are hilarious like i
love the kind i love the back and forth
between there's only like a couple
scenes of it but it's just like really
really funny and later on i'm pretty
sure because i was like did wait did i
just see that i'm pretty sure that like
shawn's dad the cop gets out of the car
and his partner is still in the car and
then like dracula blows the car up and
i'm like wait did that dude just die
like did he just get blown up and like
burned alive i'm pretty sure he did
like because they don't like see him but
afterward i'm just like holy [ __ ] i
can't believe they [ __ ] so they kill
a lot of people in this and there's a
thing too where rudy the greaser kid he
um you know he's got this like he
[ __ ] straight up shoots the werewolf
like with the silver he steals a gun
from a cop or whatever uh that's knocked
out and puts he had made silver bullets
in uh in his high school shop class and
he puts the silver bullets in there and
straight up shoots the werewolf um and
then the werewolf turns back into a guy
and is like thank you so you know what i
mean so it makes it good but he also
straight up like stakes a bunch of
vampires brides like i was just like
writing the thing so you know so it's a
little
it's a little intense for a kid's movie
and i think maybe that's why like i said
nowadays people watch it and it's you
know it's
it's not offensive nowadays really but i
kind of feel like back then it didn't
really know
what its audience was exactly because it
just went
pretty far in like a horror and violence
sort of direction in like an adult
language and stuff like that
maybe like went a little bit older
than
you know that the audience that it was
aiming at but
just like a lot of things that came out
that didn't really find their audience
at the time that it came out maybe you
know 1987 wasn't the time for this maybe
if they'd waited a couple years but i
just i like that
movies like this that are really kind of
like a product of their time but they're
also kind of like ahead of their time a
little bit so i kind of like that
over the years like after it was on
cable and after it came out on vhs and
after like people started to see it
people started remembering it fondly so
it got this massive massive cult
following to the point like i said now
where there's documentaries about it
you know called like i said wolfman's
gotten arts they've seen t-shirts that
say wolf man's got nards on it that have
like quotes from the movie and [ __ ] like
that and i was watching uh send a
massacre they they did like this big
long panel discussion about it and it's
funny because one of them actually
didn't see it back in the old days
they're like they didn't have any um you
know nostalgic sort of uh thing for it
and he was kind of like well he didn't
really think it worked because a lot of
the plot was like not explained and
everything seemed to happen really
quickly and stuff but he was
acknowledging like how great the um the
makeup effects were like the monsters
and stuff but he didn't get into it as
much honestly though it's like i didn't
i saw it back in the day but it wasn't
one that really stuck with me but the
more times i see it the more i like it i
think like the more i appreciate it the
older i get because like i said i kind
of feel like i watched it a couple years
ago and i remember liking it but being
like well it's it seemed like a lot of
stuff happened or a lot of stuff wasn't
explained and you know there wasn't
i don't know it didn't seem like some of
the
plot points didn't seem to connect all
that well but then when i watched it
again earlier i was kind of like oh you
know what it's like this is just like a
fun
it's just a fun movie and i just and
honestly like a lot of the lines in it
like made me laugh a lot more i think
than they did the first time i saw it
because i was like oh man i forgot how
funny this was and man i forgot how good
that mummy looked and that great scene
where the mummy's trying to like you
know grab onto the back of their car and
like they the the the greaser kid like
has the has the uh what do you call
those things the bow and arrow and uh he
gets one of the bandages like in the
arrow and like unravels the mummy and
it's like all the un the bandages
unravel and then he's just like this
little ancient looking skull and it's
just it looks so great that [ __ ] gill
man looks great all the monsters look
fantastic and the dude that plays
dracula is also great he's just like
really really scary and really menacing
and it's just one of the best draculas
honestly and i kind of feel like he
doesn't get a lot of
love for it but yeah i mean well you
know like i said should you let like
little little kids watch this for
halloween no probably not because like i
said there's a lot a lot of swearing and
there's a lot of really scary
stuff in it you know that's probably
more adult than a kid should be watching
but you know kids that are like is that
tweens i don't think they'd have a
problem watching this maybe it would be
weird i would be interested to see how a
modern 12 year old would take this movie
because it is you know it is very 80s
but
i don't know i'd be curious so if any of
y'all have any like 12 year old kids and
you want to show them this movie this
halloween and see what they say about it
i'm genuinely curious because it's hard
for me to
to judge because you know i don't have
any kids and i don't know any 12 year
olds uh nowadays so i don't really know
like what the difference would be but
i'm curious to know anyway now
interestingly when i first planned to do
this movie
for uh for my halloween week it was on
hulu but then when i went and looked
this morning it's not there anymore so i
actually had to rent it uh on youtube so
know that going if you have hulu it was
on there up to like a week ago but now
it's gone so but you can rent it on
youtube i think it was 3.99 uh so you
know it's a it's a good it's not really
necessarily set around halloween but you
know because it's monsters and [ __ ] like
that it seems like a very halloweeny
type movie to me so i really wanted to
do it uh for this and like i said i
could have sworn that we did it before
but i guess we didn't i mean unless it
got taken down i really don't remember
but yeah so if any of you guys saw this
either when you were a kid or you saw it
recently i'd be interested to hear
everybody's kind of thoughts on it um
you know so let me know down in the
comments what you thought of the monster
squad and i will see you on the next
review bye
[Music]
you